Square
in 1993,
Boutros Boutros Oh,
could also be called Boutros.
Boutros Boutros rally.
He,
he was secretary general of United
Nations and eminent French defied the
option who in 1993 he said,
well,
it says we have to have democracy in
Somalia for which we will have to build
the economy,
rebuild the economy.
We want to have to build.
The political institutions will have to
brill,
build a democratic state,
will have to build the court system left
to do this,
and you have to do that.
And the other.
Now that seems like a completely lunatic
program,
you're going to go to a place like
Somalia.
You're going to build these things,
but reflect Boutros,
Boutros,
Boutros.
Ghali came from Egypt and in Egypt they
have parliament that courts,
they have all of these things coexisting
with an undiminished dictatorship.
So for embroiders galleys idea,
you just go and set up.
You'll get a building and you call it
the parliament building.
You create another,
another building called the electoral
commission,
and then you have.
You will summon different people and
say,
you're going to organize the Democratic
Party and you're going to organize the
central party and you're going to
organize the patriotic party.
You better be smart about that,
and so that was the idea of creating
democracy for the secretary general of
United Nations in 1993 was something
that was very straightforward because
you had the Egyptian case,
a great warning there in the case of
Egypt,
because you'll have all the forms,
the externally created externally
induced forms which actually provide
extremely comfortable framework for a
dictatorship.
If you believe that the unity of the
humanity is broken,
that it is separated into humanities,
like specialists and different space,
yes,
then you are completely disarmed.
You have no weapon and no tool to
protest or to react to a flagrant
injustice,
a bloodbath or gen site in the name of
what should you react to the genocide in
Rwanda or to the beginning of genocide
in Darfur.
If you don't believe that democracy is
for everyone,
if you believe like,
hey girl and Spangler,
that humanity in divided into different
spaces and so on and so that's why.
If you oppose the motion,
it is not because I believe that we
shall build all of a sudden tomorrow
morning a fake British parliamentary
democracy in the disaster,
the inhabited areas of dark pool,
which I visited a few weeks ago.
Of course not in these parts of Africa
where the human cleansing has been
nearly achieved.
Of course windows have them ocracy
coming from from the soil,
but believing that democracy is for
everyone just means that you have
enhance some tools,
some arguments,
some worlds,
some values which are low you to condemn
what is happening.
For example,
in doctoral.